but with just 2 2 days until
you are the ultimate jury and the
election takes place
let's turn back to the campaign trail
where joe biden has finally
mustered up the courage to leave his
basement bunker for a few hours in fact
joe even left his home state of delaware
today a rare occurrence for the weak
frail
cognitively struggling democrat and
lentils to say
he was totally overwhelmed at one point
he confused
robert byrd with ted kennedy at another
point joe could not even remember
senator mitt romney's name referring to
him as that
that mormon watch this you may remember
i got in trouble when we were running
against the senator who was a mormon
uh the governor okay and i took him on
anybody
no one's face to be questioned the the
mormon guy
the mormon hold these truths to be
someone all men are created equal doubt
by the thing you know
what you know whatever the thing god the
creator of everything so that's how
biden's day began
and it only got worse from there mr joe
30330 once again struggling to
literally completely promote a campaign
website and by the way
maybe somebody on a staff might want to
remind the ever forgetful joe that he's
running for
president he's not running for senator
keeps forgetting forgets the day of the
week forgets what office he's running
for
he's running for president not senator
somebody remind him
take a look you know we have to come
together that's why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate
so vote vote visit iowa.com
ohio god bless you
uh can somebody tell joe by the way it's
not a real website
and joe you're running for president not
senator and by the way that senator the
mormon guy
is mitt romney not some mormon governor
now sadly what we showed you that's just
from a couple of hours today
because every time that joe actually
leaves the basement bunker
and stays out past 10 am well
disaster ensues here's a quick reminder
look tomorrow's superstar tuesday and i
want to thank you all
i tell you what i'm rushing ahead aren't
i we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing
if you agree with me go to joe 303
we choose truth over facts play the
radio make sure the television
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night
the the phone make sure the kids hear
words poor kids are just as bright and
just as talented white kids
donald trump does pose an excellent
strength to this
the it's not hypothetical
this is pretty serious by the way these
are way beyond an occasional campaign
gaffe
and i am beginning well i'm more than a
little worried that this man
could represent a clear and present
danger to this country
he's obviously not capable of leading
he's been hiding the entire campaign
and the corrupt media mob is covering
for him
joe wants to be the president of the
united states of america
that would be the toughest job in the
world and at times
joe doesn't seem to remember that he's
even running for president
or what state he's in or what day of the
week it is does anyone
really believe that if elected that joe
biden will actually be in control of
anything
which then brings up another scary
thought that would be his most
radical vice presidential running mate
kamala harris
now he knows as radical socialist base
they're going to be the ones in charge
that's kamala harris that's bolshevik
bernie that's aoc
and by the way they are saying what
their stated plans are
are to fundamentally transform this
country
court packing ending the legislative
filibuster
what starting the process to ban the
electoral college
adding d.c puerto rico as states oh
four more democrats so you have a
democratic-run senate
in perpetuity it would be the biggest
power grab in the history of the country
then they want open borders why they
hope all the 11
15 million people that get amnesty
they're hoping that they will vote
democrat
according to chuck schumer he said it
everything is on the table
now at least one emboldened far left
activist group
they've even posted online a guide on
how to disrupt and shut down
this entire country by force if the 2020
race is too close to call
we'll have more on that coming up in a
special report but first
here is what president trump had to say
about his struggling
democratic opponent and his radical base
take a look
sleepy joe biden not a nice guy by the
way i have to be honest not a nice guy
you know people say oh he's such a nice
guy
he had a very bad day today he had a
very bad day you saw what happened
if i ever had a day like he had today
then say it's over
it's over we have somebody running who's
not 100
he's not 80 percent he's not 60 percent
we can't have this as a country we can't
have it
by the way a tribute to the great
researchers and scientists
the new therapeutics that they have
developed to help people overcome covert
19
is unbelievable and we are on our way
towards a vaccine on top of that
with operation warp speed